Mollie Kuramoto liable careful guys make
sure that you try these supplements out
there very very good very healthy
natural and you can check the link in
the description box that is nature's
blend black seed oil and they have other
things as well it's a boy boy boy hope
you enjoyed the video welcome to another
podcast of the green room we're joined
with a very special guest today I'm
going to introduce he's a professor of
philosophy at Astoria research professor
of philosophy Azusa Pacific University
he specializes in analytic metaphysics
with interest in mind with interests in
mind and philosophy of religion his name
is Joshua Rasmussen how you doing presto
Josh I'm doing great thank you you okay
is it pleasure to be with you
it's a very big pleasure I mean I've
been reading your book which I recommend
for people to actually buy it's a book
called necessary existence which which
covers some very personal important
arguments for God's existence or the
existence of a necessary being could you
tell us just in brief of what this book
is all about okay yeah so that book
necessary existence
that's about using the tools of
philosophy and reasoning to argue as you
put it for a necessary foundation or a
thing that cannot not be and has the
power to produce other things and and I
just want to add here it might even my
more recent book how reason can lead to
God I build on this argument for a
necessary foundation and argue that this
necessary foundation would also have a
supreme nature would actually be God in
a classical sense so the book is divided
into this one which I'm familiar with
because I've pretty much read it it's
divided into about six chapters so one
of them is a traditional course based
contingency argument and then one of
them relies all the add the rest of the
arguments five five other arguments
relies on modal logic is
is that about correct yeah in the sense
that there are arguments from
possibility so what's very interesting
about those chapters as we show that we
show independent reasons to think that
it's just possible that there's this
necessary foundation and then using
modal logic the logic of possibility
necessity we deduce that if that's
possible then there really is such such
a thing and then and there's a big
second vertical path but yeah go ahead
then there's a father of the of the book
which deals with kind of like objection
handling so I wanted to I want to start
off with the actual argument itself you
mentioned that the argument can be made
on kind of causal lines and explanatory
lines what is what is the argument in a
nutshell how would you explain it to
maybe a lay audience how do you prove
the existence of a necessary being yeah
so I I think of in terms of pathways and
so now I like to build pathways that
start with people's own position in fact
I have a website called necessary being
calm and this is just a survey site and
it asks you your about your beliefs and
it shows how to deduce a pathway from
your beliefs to a necessary being yes
now in the one of the opening chapters
our opening argument gives a kind of
classical pathway and and this kind of
simple formulation of that goes like
this
there's no premise 1 any contingent
portion of reality or any contingent
thing or things is going to depend on
something it's gonna be caused by
something or you know it's not going to
just exist on its own there's gonna be
something else that produces it then the
next premise would be something like if
every contingent portion of reality has
a cause or depends on something then
there's got to be some kind of non
contingent or necessary portion of
reality and so therefore there is a
necessary or non-contingent portion of
reality so that would be a simple
formulation of the argument and in in
terms of proving now that this is
something more than I'd want to go
straight into objections because I want
to spend a bit of time with you but
someone could say well this is this is a
mental construction
I mean what you're talking about here is
it's conceivable possibly in the mind
only is this correct or could this be
something which is applicable to both
the so-called real world around us as
well as as being a mental construction
yeah I know I really appreciate this
question because it gets at this more
basic question about like how we can
know anything yes about anything right
yeah like why I think that the thoughts
that we have in our own minds apply to
the actual world outside our minds right
but if you start thinking about it it
you can sort of test this by a principle
of self defeat I mean so like let's say
that you say that well reality is
completely unknowable and nothing you
say about reality can be true hmm well
is that true right is that true about
reality right but
and so that's self-defeating because as
soon as you say that you can't say
anything about reality you've just said
something about reality yes